es momento de hablar de economía quien
france24 y por ello recibo y con mucho
gusto a daniela blandón ramírez la
especialista económica daniela que bueno
empezar con una noticia pues favorable y
es que en américa latina comienzan a
recobrarse los empleos a las muy buenas
noches pues por fin tenemos una noticia
buena tres países dieron a conocer este
viernes su más reciente cifra de
desempleo en la región chile bajó su
tasa del 12,3 por ciento en el tercer
trimestre cinco puntos más que hace un
año pero es mejor que el máximo
histórico que se alcanzó del 13,1 por
ciento registrado hace un par de meses
en colombia también bajó en septiembre
por segundo mes consecutivo se ubicó en
el 15,8 por ciento cuando hace un año
era del 10,2
este fenómeno ataca más a las mujeres en
colombia pues estima que un 20 por
ciento no tiene empleo la mala noticia
es para brasil la situación es distinta
la tasa de desempleo tocó un nuevo
récord del 14,4 por ciento entre junio y
agosto y en consecuencia el número de
personas ocupadas
se ubicó en el mínimo histórico hoy son
81 7 millones de personas que sí tienen
trabajo en brásil de sudamérica vámonos
al norte del continente y es que en eeuu
ya se permite viajar en los cruceros si
las autoridades sanitarias de este país
levantaron este viernes la prohibición a
la navegación de cruceros en los puertos
la parálisis duró casi 8 meses y se
estima que sólo en florida a donde llega
la mayoría ha dejado pérdidas de más de
22 mil millones de dólares y a casi 170
mil personas sin empleo la apertura no
obstante va a ser condicionada y
escalonada no es ya la primera fase de
reapertura requiere pruebas para los
miembros de la tripulación también había
habrá viajes simulados para que las
autoridades se aseguren de que se va a
mitigar al máximo el riesgo de contagio
después de todo eso sí vendrá el
esperado regreso gradual de los cruceros
muy bien pues en la unión europea
también la economía se recuperó en el
tercer trimestre
bueno al menos si se compara frente al
trimestre anterior es decir entre abril
y junio los 27 países del bloque
comunitario registraron en el tercer
trimestre el mayor crecimiento desde que
iniciaron los registros en 1995 fue del
12,1 por ciento eso gracias al fin de
las restricciones impuestas en la
primavera para combatir la pandemia así
que esperemos como sigue ahora y así
como francia españa e italia se han
llevado la peor parte en los trimestres
anteriores pues esta vez lideraron el
rebote económico hablan con crecimientos
de hasta dos dígitos pero eso no quiere
decir que hayan salido de la recesión y
mucho menos ahora con las nuevas
restricciones que podrían empeorar el
panorama de aquí a final de año de hecho
si se compara con el mismo período del
año pasado que es como normalmente suele
verse esta cifra la unión europea mostró
una contracción conjunta del 39 por
ciento también en méxico buenas
económicas no de jugo signos de
recuperación en méxico su país el
producto interno bruto repuntó un 12%
tercer trimestre lo mismo frente a los
tres meses anteriores lo hizo gracias a
la reactivación social y económica del
país aunque la cifra de contagios de
coronavirus como sabemos en este país se
acerca al millón y la de muertos a los
100.000 sin embargo al igual que en
europa o en eeuu
el resultado trimestral no muestra nos
muestra es la tendencia que ha habido
durante la pandemia por eso es normal
que el pib suba en un trimestre en el
que terminaron los confinamientos pero
nunca hay que dejar de lado la
comparación frente al trimestre del año
pasado en este caso si se registró una
caída del 8,6 por ciento en el caso
mexicano eso apunta a que si bien se
está recuperando la economía todavía
está muy lejos de los niveles pre
pandémicos indicadores económicos de
este 30 de octubre al mercado no le
convencieron los buenos resultados de
las tecnológicas apple amazon y facebook
hoy se desplomaron y arrastraron a wall
street' que despide su peor mes desde
marzo en europa cada país se reaccionó
distinto al dato de crecimiento
económico madrid- subió después de
cuatro sesiones consecutivas
y en américa latina la bolsa de sao
paulo se desplomó casi un 7% en la
semana y perdió un 3% las cifras del día
son las 25 mil hectáreas que dedica
anualmente la unión europea para
cultivar calabazas cuya mayor venta al
año ocurre para esta época del año que
es halloween según eurostat
muy bien daniela pues muchas gracias por
este recorrido económico ya ustedes
muchas veces por su compañía de hamás en
france24
[Música]